non je peux vous dire il ya des
violences policières si ça vous fait
plaisir que je le dise je les dis je
récuse totalement ce terme de violences
policières
il faut pas confondre d'abord de choses
qui sont les risques terroristes et à
dangerosité et le phénomène des
migrations
si on veut lutter contre le terrorisme
de manière efficace il faut cesser de
nier le lien entre terrorisme et
immigration
deux mâles blancs ne vivent pas dans ces
quartiers s'échange rapport et le 10 ans
découvert c'est que j'ai été
profondément choqué par les propos du
président de la république sur les mâles
blancs je suis une femelle blanche et je
revendique d'avoir quelque chose à dire
sur l'avenir de ces grands lieux de ces
quartiers populaires
des constructeurs mais moi je crois que
le rôle d'un président de la république
s'est pas de déconstruire l'histoire de
france je pense le rôle d'un président
de la république c'est d'incarner la
fierté nationale
quant aux parents ils ont trouvé le
jeune souvent des gens ne sont pas prêts
nous mettrons d'ailleurs une prime de
1000 euros supplémentaires en plus des
rémunérations habituel des stagiaires de
la formation professionnelle pour
permettre à tous les chômeurs qui le
souhaitent de se reconvertir vers ces
métiers en tension
concrètement 14 réacteurs de 900
mégawatts seront arrêtées d'ici à 2035
je reviendrai sur le programme de
fermeture anticipée les viserait heures
lancerait un nouveau programme pour
l'univers c'est dans ce sens
des choses atroces des barbaries des
crimes et délits ont été commis c'est
comme parler de crimes contre l'humanité
à propos de la colonisation
voyez c'est de la réécriture exposé de
l'histoire je ne laisserai pas réécrire
l'histoire de france